IY THATNT STS EVENT.MER VICE P
RIGHT TOURE ECTION.
SI VOTER F OREGULARITIES EXIST,
T
CHANGE THE VER
ESIDENT TO H
THRI ENSURTE.
THS RIGHT.D EVERYONE KNOWSTINTEE
VIDEO ON FRIDAEV
HENNECTION WITH JANUARY 6 INRSO.
OFFICOU
PP B USED AGAINST
POLICE GUARDING THE PITOL.VERBA
AGAINST THE VICE PTCTHF YOUR YOI
TWGU THE RIGHT SID SCREEN.
HERE COMES ONE OF .S WITH THE H.
WATCH S  UP IN AN AND
HE
LOOKS LI LITTLE LY CLUIGHT
.
AL THI MBERS
JANUARY 6thD ADAM KIZINR.
REPRESENTATIVES ARE
GOP MITT ROMNEYHORAT-LE RESPONN
THE TWEETED, SHAMFALLS ON WHOO
IN VITT         RIOLTAENND
AM.LI AND
ADAM THEY AR
HUH?E SPEAKER WITH THAPPED
TRN A  UNDER TO PRTOREEY, BUT CH
PRESIDENTIAL
AND SECRET HDOD
WHICH HAVE RGS
CONSPIRACY.
DEVELOPMEN
RECORDS REVEAL OE MORNINOF
JANUARY 6th THFO
IVE JIM
OKAY.FICATN BIDEL  AFTATTACK.FTO
SO WHAESL ?
I'THAT FORMER
E PENSION
EV OF THINGS THAT
SOCIETY WE AT REBUKE
OFR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE. RIGHT T
THE ELECTION.
EVEO FAR  TCALL THATTN UNME
SOMETHELSE, PENCE'S CHOICE
SALT LAKED HAVE TO THC
INFE PANNED OSE TO BREAKP ONSTIT
ORSTS.ER WORDS, THE
TRY
INTERPRETED H IS WHY PENCE
TIED H  OF THE CONSTIEY WOULD G.
IFRER BE OR
RIGHLEANING LAERE, WEL IAND BYOH
DET KAMALA
HARRIS WLDE
OF POWER BAS HE GUARANTEL
MITICALLY BRILLIANT.PENCE' HIS
FORMER BOSAN
URE OF TOPT MA BEEN JUST A HAND
ESTABLISHMENT REPUBLAN
Y FIND THEIR HOW FAR
PRESIDENT PENCE IS WILLING TO
H, T'E E TESTS
SO FND  6th COMMISSIRA FORMEAIDN
THREE-STAR GAL
SECURIT
AT OWT YOU THK.
SMERCONISH.COMS SURVEY
QUESTION.
STIFY BEFORE 6th
YES  NO?RU RFIES OCOERLAW.ING M.
PRREJECT OF  C APE "WASHINGTONLL
>>NOT.
THAT WAS NEV CE CAN 2020.N
2024.CE PRENT
ABSOLUTEORCTTHAT POWER.S G
>>L TH
TELIR ORIGINALIS
INTERPRETATION, SOMETHING
THE FEDERALIST SOCTY WOULD
>> Y.E VICE PRESIDENT DIDT .Y CU
RATE THEY BENNDERS WARE OF T
VI PSI OINWE
THEY KPRESID
POWER AND THEIR PRACTICE AT TH
CEVER
MEANT VI
THATER.KA
MOVE AFOOT TO MODIFY THEAW SAIDH
>> FOR ELECT
T OFIS
AT'S WHY THERE WAS CONFUSI
WHAT THE VICE PRESIDENT'S LEGAL
PORSIN1.HOULD BEHA
REBUT THERE'S HER,S MO ALTHOUGH
PRIDWERS IT GIVES
CORESSAT
S88UEAC
YESE MOST
PROBLEM WAS,IOUSLY I2021
BUT THERE HAVE BEEOBJECTIONS
BEFORE ANDT HAONT ERT IT'S
COME FROM ESND
THAT'S IMPORO MB
DE OD TORS OF THE
RE-ELECTION OF ESONT VOTINGINENG
SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN BROUGHT.NETA
AY OVERTURNS  2024.THATBVIOUSLE
Y THE
>>OUR U HAVEELL.
TAUGHT ABOUT DISPUTES
INCLUDING HAY RV
SHEDSKSS.E WAR GAME
SCS.
MOST ABOUT
2024?
THAT  OAST  THE MOST IS INTERF
ITTION
OF THE SENATE HAMO
ANEAR FROMATORSONABLE.
ROMNEY CS JUAT THERE ARE A LARGF
SENATORS IN THE REPUBLIC PWHO MT
THAT, ABOUT THVES.
D REPRESENTAVEcCARS
THIS
VOLUMES.ALSETORIAL
THOSE ND AREN SWING STATES
RESULTS IN 2020 AND  D
SO I
MD ABOUT IS THAT A RNOR,  GOVER